home that aren't familiar with the
Metroid franchise this is in tendo's
premier exploration based sci-fi action
game it features Samus Aran who is a
renowned bounty hunter and she's been
sent by the Galactic Federation to
Planet sr388 to investigate and
annihilate the Metroid's she's the best
at what she does oh yeah she's super
cool and this is actually a reimagine a
ssin of the original Gameboy classic
that was released in 1991 Metroid to
return of Samus and this game is just
it's beautiful it's a little bit shinier
than they go yeah yes it is and it's
this game is still about discovery and
exploration you know there's intense
boss battles and there's so many
pathways to discover and you can take
your time through it and this is really
this is classic 2d Metroid to a tee it's
got the isolation the exploration and of
course Samus just generally being
amazing yeah and the great thing about
those being on on the 3ds is that this
there is so much detail in the
background and its really heightened
with the 3d feature on and you can't see
it at home right now but it does feel
really really good yeah it sounds cheesy
but it adds a lot of depth to the
experience yeah oh and something I want
to actually show here on the show floor
so in the past Samus was able to aim at
45-degree angles but now she has this
whole range of motion which really
allows for precision here it's really
nice because especially as you get
further into the game their enemies all
over the place so having the freedom to
shoot anywhere you like is incredible
yeah so the free game oh so the free
game here is also really cool here where
when I'm actually moving it and I
actually have an enemy on site and
target it the the queue will audio cue
will change and also that it will
highlight address so again it allows for
a little bit more precision here and
it's still up to you to aim precisely
but that's nice visual indicator is just
very helpful yeah and Sam is here has
four very basic abilities and so as I
keep exploring and seeing new
environments I'll hopefully gather new
abilities to upgrade my suit so this is
another new ability that Sam has has in
this game it's a melee counter and if I
time it appropriately and immediately
shoot
I have I do a critical hit on the enemy
but in the circumstance that I don't
immediately shoot I have some time to
actually just shoot from afar and take
give a give myself a little bit more
leeway to not get it doesn't mean the
counter is a new ability as you
mentioned and it's really great because
this game gets challenging oh yeah very
very difficult and since you have some
motifs on here while we're speaking
about challenges perhaps you could tell
us a little bit about some of the
challenges you encountered while
developing this game oh no cause a
little piano chi-chi-chi me 800 requests
so challenger cuz i wanna hi I know we
don't we don't accountable to deny in
the scary the war I know our okay no
concrete Sarita game design no game mama
da choppah to Donna Hatteras video so
Claire's in a photo vamoose Kozhikode
yeah well I mean I think I don't know if
it's you qualified it is a big challenge
but something that we face whenever
we're working on it on something like
this with an established style of
gameplay it's adding you know what sort
of new elements can we add to something
that again is established and has had
you know had some success in the past
token II I know you have a new series
Honoka target Arab Amanda who stated I
get there so DJ's shigeaki tickity human
about so it goes on a hidden Idol at a
fight a demon yes I mean I really felt
that it would be difficult or could be
difficult to bring in new elements that
would have a lot of excitement and at
the same time make the fans of the
franchise you know happy and satisfied I
know demo con carne asada taco de
combustion but you know I think this
time with samus returns I think we've
done a really good job
Nautica dude I know what the shake is
your name I know super arcpad on anemia
da da da and why is that because we
found this really amazing partner to
work with market these teams obviously
and that's mercury steam hasan you got
thought thank you very much Jose thanks
to you
yes thanks to both of you and after
we're speaking you actually got stamens
legendary morph ball ability I did and
this is very very handy to get as you
can see through certain tunnels here
here's a save station which oh right me
right now I'm gonna keep on going and
exploring this area and here there's
this is a pretty weak area from where I
just was and you'll see this gate here
this is a little different from the
original game yeah it definitely is and
from people that haven't played the
metroid 2 in the past this purple liquid
is actually very painful and I'll just
kind of get down oh yeah she did it yeah
yeah so I can't really go down there and
I want to and I can't really interact
with this right now so I'm gonna keep on
moving forward and see and that's really
that's the nature of this game is you'll
come across areas that you just can't
survive in yet you just can't get past
and you'll have to acquire new tools and
abilities to be able to keep exploring
and keep pushing forward
exactly so since I couldn't go through
the door I went up and around it so I'm
going to keep on moving forward and this
is also a brand new feature to the
Metroid franchise these are a on
abilities a on is a very mystical and
powerful energy source and they actually
give abilities to Samus that are very
different from the technical upgrades
that she gets for her suit so this one
that I just gathered is called the scam
holes and what it was is that oh I
should remind people that the Aeon
abilities are actually not their limited
you can't just display on them whatever
you want to and so they'll have their
own energy and you'll have to gather a
power of power-ups for them and also
more energy in order to refill that tank
just to show place can pull yeah so to
showcase the singham pulse if you see
the bottom screen the map usually kind
of a of the explorers once you start
moving but if I use the scan pulse
turn up this quadrant of map already for
me and also on the upper screen will
show these box that I can easily break
so now I know that oh there was an
actual hidden path there so and normally
you would just have to shoot everywhere
to try and find breakable blocks and you
can still do it that way if you want to
but if you have the a on to pull it off
the scan pulse is also very very helpful
yeah I keep in mind though that not
everything can be easily broken with
your laser so yeah that's kind of some
ammo that you'd have to waste and it's
it's nice to actually have the an
ability to strategize about you know
what which one am I gonna use am I gonna
use my ammo or am I gonna use on the a
on ability in order to keep on
discovering exploring absolutely and you
know throughout her long career samus
has had a lot of unique abilities at her
disposal and as we've seen already this
game adds even more so Jose perhaps you
could tell us a little bit about the
process you guys went through of adding
new abilities like the melee counter or
the Aeon abilities yes well from the
beginning sakimoto-san wanted me
Christine to challenge ourself to bring
new ideas to a series so we were given
freedom to put a title at all different
ideas some mechanics and secret run to
better fit within the metroid universe
while this ideas a mechanic's well
discover it was just a matter of
iterating and publishing a design how
wonderful they really add a lot to the
experience so good work definitely do
so here is an energy station and I'm a
little bit low so I'm just gonna take
that you always want to take advantage
of both editing stations every little
bit of health matters yeah for sure
you'll notice that a beeping started
that's actually my Metroid detector
telling me that there is a metroid
nearby again from people that don't
really know what Metroid's are you're an
alien species that they're pretty
dangerous and they suck up the light
form of any alien species in order to
survive yeah you don't want to hug a
Metroid necessarily
yeah exactly another thing I want to
showcase here is actually the mapping
system that this game has so now that in
case I not able to go through a door
because I don't have the ability to
unlock it which happens a lot yes
I have these pins now that I can just
drop it onto the mat and then that will
kind of be my note for myself so oh I
want to revisit this later once I grab
an ability and maybe I could try it
later and as you mentioned this game is
so much about exploration and going back
and trying to find every Square and shut
the map find all of this mini hidden
secrets so this pin system is actually
very very yeah oh I'm getting close but
I'm gonna go investigate this area your
Metroid senses are still tingling so
keep searching
keep getting closer cuz the beeping is
getting a little bit more insistent oh
nice
found a hidden missile tank yeah but say
there was an example where I kind of
knew already let those pass what's there
but the scam pulse would have been very
useful right there to kind of show those
box there's another safe station so
cereal samples told me that that block
is breakable but I can't shoot it so I'm
gonna try a missile instead it's opened
and that's a good point if you ever run
into an area you can't progress past use
all of your weapons and yes oh it's a
little friend a friend that's a Metroid
but we're actually not fighting him
actually fighting hits first evolution
and this is known the Alpha Metroid you
look slice as friendly as a regular
that's good so if I time it correctly I
can actually melee counter him and it
gives me an advantage to actually hit
him for more damage you also see that
he'll drop these little sparks by
actually a hit those perks
I'll get more replenished amaura
so in case I am end up using all of my
missiles I could always go around him
and try to shoot those in order to get
more missiles nice my Lady Catherine and
I'll say I don't know how well the home
audience can hear this but the sound
effects in this game are incredible the
music the atmospheric sounds are just
really great so Sakamoto son perhaps you
could tell us a little bit about what
into went into the development of the
soundtrack for this game oh it does
sound Turia a scenic artist a nomadic I
have to Sonos a sarcastic angie is an
oil you know look at the echo not only
cheetah honey she stated I can touch I
know con que no sabes retardo diva supa
Metroid oh no toki no hemos hablado
composer study Sanka see we have two of
the composers who worked on Super
Metroid on the team for Santos we trans
Cairo no sora co no metroid OCD Zozo
Kanako doto campos de paso no de modo
ganodi muy you a doctor - vamos
Cosi Cosi Tioga Kodo teeka's to create a
demo and you know and they've worked on
pretty much every Metroid title since
that time doing music for us um and so I
really don't have to say any anything
they just go do what they do and what
they do is create great music excellent
we'll lock them up don't ever let them
go oops
so you made quick work of that alphabet
right good work I said so I'm actually
gonna go return to that gate that I
couldn't get to before see what happens
make my way there so in the original
Metroid to whenever you defeated a
certain prerequisite number of Metroid's
the ground would Rumble and then you
would know that you would be able to
proceed to the next area so now in this
game you have these gates and they press
on it and you enter the Metroid DNA that
you had just gathered from the Metroid
you just killed it will enter into this
gate unlock reduce this hazardous liquid
that was killing me before and now I'm
able to get to the next area it's really
cool having this really visual cue of
your progress in the game as well yeah
so now I'm gonna go to a later area in
the game and we've gotten a glimpse of
it a little bit but the 3ds hardware
really goes a long way in bringing this
world to life it helps communicate the
isolation of Samus being stuck on this
alien planet
so I'm sakimoto-san could you speak a
little to how you use to the 3ds tech to
bring this world to life and really
reimagine it at OCD be a pseudo Gidget
sudah it or botanique on a Twinkie man
for a rainy taco no michi no wax a
summer's night
Torino Hoboken Oh your Atacama Desert or
- nah 3d SEO
each at all you can he's gonna give his
boat's captain kono sekai all so go see
now sorry television hi I'm Tanya nose
territory
okay no pasado so novo no Gabrus any
Coco diva
oh no CDs ODI Steve oh no God no she's
only kolkata Toma what ha ha ha ha ha
did you Clementi hoses Oh Monica I saw
yeah I mean I do think that with this
title of course with samus the three be
the glasses-free 3d the 3d effects are
put to great use it really does help
build the world that we're exploring but
I like to go ahead and ask Jose to talk
a little bit about some of the more
technical aspects yes it was very clear
to us from the beginning that if we
wanted to convert to the player the
greatness of the unit that sort of done
it and the past the glory of the social
security system we had to provide a bit
sense of scale thanks to the dev and
given by the 3ds capability so we want
it to the flatfish from if you only the
development process this is going
through the first division of the parts
well can you cut yourself in trouble
Teresa I always do I ran into his room
and he didn't like me be welcome up from
a nap you know that but I'm stuck here
and so he gives me leave and now it's
not the time to play with it necessarily
but I was point out that you also got
your spider ball that's great that's
right and I yeah I also got a bombs here
so these are actually very handy for
taking them out oh my gosh so will you
play with your new friend um
this is obviously an enemy from the
original game and that brings to mind
the fact that all of the enemies can
actually be redesigned to this version
so Jose perhaps you could tell us a
little bit about what the process was
for redesigning the enemies yes we
wanted to display the visual design of
the real enemies as as much as possible
and but we had to adapt the attacks
movements and behaviors so they could
fit with other new gameplay and without
making them lose much of the original
field in the process and as for the
Metroid's they were the stars of the
show along the same OSINT original game
and this we wanted also to be the same
in our game and they well they suffered
a massive overhaul from the visual so
original game their gameplay mechanics
and also we want it too creepy so the
transition in the lie
one time I tried to another this is
something that is very clearly reflected
and women's behaviour on an attack thank
you and good work tree
hi thank you so I could actually take
the spider ball and the spider ball is
actually an ability here that's very
very unique to metroid 2 um but i'm
actually gonna do a very hard Technip it
I'm not too in very good right now I
swear I practice though the blob jump oh
no all right last my preventive spent
hours trying to get the craziest places
you think pumped up oh no but I'm s
you're trying to work your way around
system app that also brings me to the
point that a lot of the maps have been
redesigned for the new system so Hosea
can you speak a little to the process of
redesigning the map as well
yes devoted to respect as much as
possible the original layout for the
original game because it has such a
listed in structure within the Metroid
series and where we want it and to add a
lot of new cities or new things because
we wanted to be fed also new and we are
the lots of sections different original
games because we wanted to accommodate
all of our gameplay names and also we
wanted again to be more disposition to
be more dynamic and diverse talent
original game introducing some closet
abilities not other games in the series
but with that were not present in the
original game and also we added some new
for special abilities that are unique to
this title so the combination of both
and made us realize some very
interesting situations you have been
double design for players to actively
figure out their way for one in new ways
actually before I take this elevator I
want to show this this is also a new
feature to Metroid Samus returns and
it's a teleport station this actually
helps a lot with the mobility of the
game where instead of backtracking all
the way through previous areas you can
actually use the teleport to quickly
jump into a new area and this actually
really helps when you're trying to
gather some items that you weren't able
to in the past or explore new pathways
that you weren't able to before
am I gonna take it right now I'm
actually gonna go back and take this
elevator to a new air
but you're right it's such a huge
addition to the game being able to more
quickly get to the areas you've already
been to and find all this juicy secrets
you weren't able to get up before well
because like gathering all these items
it actually rewards you in the end
because it gets it does get more
difficult as you further get into the
planet and the baddies you get really
hard so you definitely want to get all
those upgrades and the items and it
rewards you but you can also choose not
to if you want a challenge so I've
visited previous lava rooms before so I
know that this red door looks a little
bit dangerous but I'm gonna go in anyway
just to share a rebel yeah it hurts yeah
I don't want that okay so um I'm gonna
actually use the scan pulse because I
see there's something up there and I'm
pretty sure there's a pathway but just
to make sure y'all you have the a on it
if you might as well there you go
excellent so we're gonna go up here
I love how if you had just shot up above
you it would have looked like there
wasn't anything to break yeah actually
good that you used to scan polls right
there yeah I I have gotten lost more
than once
here's another suit upgrade
let's feel really good he's really okay
I love how vibrant the colors are it's
just this world is so much I just know
people yeah
and it's just again it's really cool
when the 3d feature is on because you
get to see all the stuff that's happened
in the background
um but yeah so I'm going to go in here
and while Samus has a classic suits yeah
very soon so I can't go here so let's
try going back to the way we came from
oh those clothes as close very close I
like to play dangerous to them and now
you can survive the day I thought so
we're gonna explore this room now and we
could always go back and explore other
lava rooms to see what we missed I have
to point out that this is all one planet
this is all sr388 but look how different
the environments are it's a big planet
oh you have a lot of different areas and
there's a lot of pretty much variety and
every every every area is just so
colorful and unique on its own so here
I'm gonna show a new an ability called
Lightning armor what it does it gives us
green glow to samus but also overcharges
my melee
and let me go through enemies without
taking much damage but it does take away
from my a on school and so I want to
actually save it in case I need it later
yeah every time you get hit it actually
makes your a on H go down so we connect
just run this foolishly through a group
of enemies unless you want to feel a lot
of pain
yeah so here's another door that I'm
unfortunately not able to get in through
so I'm gonna do another pin here but I'm
also gonna show here there's this
information screen that will actually
see it will show different items that
are shown in the map and if you're not
quite sure what that icon means will
actually tell you here and it will
actually unlock to once you've
discovered it and you know how to
interact with it so definitely keep
keeping an eye on these because these
are actually really informative it'll
help you remember what you already know
yeah and we've pretty seen a few new a
chozo artifacts but that brings me to
the question sakimoto-san can you tell
us a little bit about the decision to
integrate more chozo artifacts into this
version of the game total metalloid Oh
game on ikura vete a casa Kalinga yo yo
yo Co Cosa Nostra das tamanho da da da
da - da da so no hikin is intercepted
Acosta I know pono game no boo dynasty
do a sriracha Haj - rakh para todo boop
mega sekai so stay home decimate okay
sugi-dono he betta butta so you know
this game is set on sr388
and it's a planet that was home to the
chozo civilisation at one point and so
it it saw the chozo flourish and it also
saw them crumble so this whole area has
this historical background of being a
place just sort of filled with with lots
of riddles Telegram
chozo boom man oh-ho shaky the other
talk so i toppled over knocks ah hi
I don't like it so that's why you see
all of these again Choza ruins that you
mentioned throughout throughout the game
estamos edit Anza son de tributo so no
boom bananas Olga are dead Walker again
I cannot oh and I think if you you know
you have a chance to play samus returns
you might find some of the answers to
the riddles that the chozo civilisation
left behind what a tease honey shudder
need not gonna come out of gen AI kappa
and but it is possible that there may be
some new and more like intriguing
riddles introduced through the game as
well fine I guess everyone's just gonna
have to wait and see look up others near
you again if I see it please do you
think you've gotten yourself into
trouble again
I did so this is the second evolution of
the Metroid species this is the gamma um
I did I was able to do a counter melee
out on him finally as he came up close
to me but I'm also gonna use ice beam
because it needs to be really weak to
his nucleus so I'm just gonna keep on
attacking him but yeah he's he's got a
dynamic set of moves he's swooping down
on me he's throwing electricity who do
you think but that's a good point if
you're ever fighting an enemy or a boss
and your weapon of choice doesn't seem
to be making a big dint try and try one
of your other weapons or abilities
because they might be a little more
successful
and since I'm a little bit low on health
I'm gonna feel safer if I put on my
lightning armor so I'm just gonna go
here
you've made him mad yeah he is not happy
with me
just gonna throw this out there the
spider legs are really creepy yeah I'm
not a fan of spiders yeah those guys
creeps me out
always turned red though so you're doing
well yes I'm there I should be almost
there
and that's another kind of visual
indicator to show you that you're
getting closer to making miss meat of
this guy yeah and there's all those
audio cues too for when when's the right
time - oh boy
Oh when's the right time to melee him so
it only happens when he goes down on the
ground but yes I was going to
successfully hit work
all right know that I actually want to
show another later area in the game cuz
I think it'd be really cool to show the
fans let's do it so while you switched
you to save file as Sakamoto Sun and
Jose we're hoping you could tell us a
little bit about how you went about
balancing this game because there's
obviously a lot of abilities and it must
have been difficult to balance making
them feel useful to players without
taking away from the challenge yeah yeah
no policy also Yemeni see Kazuto so no
balance - oh my god hey musica Chico -
Ariano ma juban an oreo kuih tako spikey
the demo company Nana cetera kuma Russia
to Arizona balance of Sonora shoka I saw
this in a partying or kudos to the
bookie - you know and obscure - so guys
SSG kept some of sky today shows you are
aware avato biscotti delegate una mas
adios well of course you know it it
feels great it's an exhilarating to use
these really powerful dime and dynamic
abilities and you know players want to
use them and we want them to use them of
course the Sonics conditional to game us
walk on Tanya
ha ha cheese amigos machinery Terry King
Joker automatic thirsty
I don't know siggy gonna DJ cut us a
decimal to mechanic Godwin but you know
one of the things we have to be careful
of is if we you know overuse them if we
make them too powerful it reduces you
know some of the tension that you feel
in the game and it sort of has the
counter effect of actually reducing the
excitement and sort of again that that's
real that we want players to feel so
again that it's a really delicate
balance some Sudha tons of the Utah the
[ __ ] past stop Kings on this a particular
key Nova Corps agama Siobhan solo de mi
hanno Kirino Barroso so he only mooska
scooty a hurry show he do their togas oh
no cocka cocka locky walk you do Co no
banana suit makuu tanoto Toledo
hezonia no tuning go for the guys if I
say I know Marcus Simmons animal maokai
guitar like I don't work well yeah I
think a good example of some of the
difficulty in that fine-tuning is what
we just saw on screen distances just
being burst and what's difficult again
about finding that balance is you have
to measure the the effect of the the
weapon and you also have to take into
fact or take into consideration the
amount of energy uses and the the supply
of energy that's available to you and
trying to come up with again a balance
that works throughout the game and keeps
all of those factors in mind it can be
quite challenging I think you know we we
put a quite a load on a mercury scheme
and having them do that but I think they
did a remarkably good job yes a
compelling sakimoto-san
Bravo
balanced abilities but only because they
can be used alone but only because they
can be used combination between them and
also they can be combined with the
closet abilities too so at the end it
was very picot up a degree however after
the confident that we finally found the
best possible balance for all players to
fully enjoy them as if you chipped a
great balance and trust me it's still
difficult all right so my Metroid
detector went off again and this is the
gamma husk so pretty sure I'm not gonna
be facing him maybe it's something
cuddlier little guy
or maybe not yeah maybe not oh this is
the next evolution this is the Zeta and
he's pretty gnarly I'm not a big fan and
as Sakamoto song was saying that about
the bean burst actually wanted to
showcase this other a on ability because
it is full power it's so cool and it
feels really powerful oh I missed my
moment into the melee and there's so
much damage - am I gonna use a
combination of abilities here from
missile to grapple to bean burst you
really have to be on your game with this
guy because he switches up his patterns
a lot oh you know hard to predict any
yeah he's hard to predict and totally
aims for me too
he's got me down nice that's just a
beautiful male a counter - I love how it
slows down time and a house that really
cinematic present a yeah so feel so epic
in action and I absolutely love it
this is my least favorite movie this one
gets me every time
oh gosh oh and now you died on purpose
so that we can zero States damage you
look so elegant they're beautiful yes so
thank you you're welcome
I aim to please yes all right I gotta
try this again yes you can do this we
all believe it I'm gonna skip the
cutscene hmm I'm gonna woo get right
into that all right nice to mail a
counter right out the top oh he was nice
enough to give it to me I'll take it yes
Oh
the other side so I gotta get shot at
the zoo close
you know he's not invited to your
birthday party anymore no ruined it I I
like green but not my face no and as a
showcasing here the new abilities you're
being burst to their your lightning
armor they add to the experience but as
to the balance they were talking about
earlier they definitely don't make it
easier you have the ion gauge and you
can't spam these abilities at all I mean
I think you yeah I got a fence hustle Oh
again it's all right three time's the
charm
he's pretty strong yeah I'm he's pretty
I'm hopeful that this third time I can
get a yes
keep the power of samus in your disposal
I have all our abilities
oh of course
whoa mister he missed you hit that time
that was lucky
he's gonna feel that tomorrow hope so so
mean
[Music]
ah
how's your favorite
Oh God absolutely
[Music]
you know he's more afraid of you than
you are of him is remember that really
like a truth I don't think he cares much
about it
[Music]
Oh
I think you have a handle on it he
switches it up oh yeah I know I always
need to be on guard with him because
it's never the same pattern or
consistent at all you're getting really
close though you can do this oh I don't
know no no don't close all right I can
do it I can do this I believe in you
this is the time and he's not gonna do
that move maybe st. over and over again
nakamoto something can be something
don't know about the good I say good
luck
yeah no pressure having a veteran
watching you
how dynamic the bean brush looks it is
until soldier
and I ran out of a on energy
ah that was my best got to do the
old-fashioned way now
missiles it is
oh oh those clothes
just stay down yeah finished just a
melee counter that's beautiful well
we're going thank you uh well that is
all we have to show for game footage but
we do have some : ounces to also show to
the folks at home so yeah I'm really
excited
Charlie oh we show alright so as you
probably might have seen in the very
beginning of the game the surface area
amiibo functionality is active in this
game it does support the - samus zero
suit samus and the regular samus from
the Super Smash Brothers line but
there's also two new amiibo that we're
so excited to show you guys so we
actually have them right here I'm gonna
ask you to help actually no I'm gonna
give you the honors over him because
he's so awesome so we got the Metroid
and this is the best part he's actually
squishy he's actually feels like a
metric Oh and he's like breaking out of
this little case and ever yeah and then
you also have Samus again here but she's
in her classic Metroid 2 pose and that
is just so so cool like the amount of
detail that's around her it's just it's
so amazing she feels so cool so yeah
these are gonna be great additions to my
collection
maybe you're collec okay definitely my
pleasure I'm a super big fan of Metroid
um so we can't unfortunately tell you
what the functionality is in this
segment but we will announce it at a
later time but we wanted to show you
these because they're so so cool yes and
uh and before we go I wanted to ask if a
Sakamoto Sun and Jose have any final
thoughts they'd like to tell our
students I wanna Anika toca toca nanka
happiest I caught on Anna Karim us reach
over man listen let's go yes I wanted to
thank sakimoto-san a Nintendo for
relying on us and to the below it is new
Metroid again
so thank you so much yeah I know but I
study more
I know market is team Santa's cuckoo
eeep autonomy we attack I know to the
Metro you know Cano say oh he'll get
rocoto addicted he's only happy yeah I
think you know we're very happy of
course to have complete haven't been
lucky enough to team up with MIT
Mercury's team on this project I really
feel that the world of the potential for
the 2d Metroid franchise has really just
opened up for us a lot so thank you so
much